ciao le sigarette non 7 siano
sigaretta thanks to home aspetto
culinario from valentia e spagna ai lobi
gusta mucho mai libero amica in erasmus
che ne a siviglia e il gioco ea trovarla
i nostri vertici perché no se spagnole
sono mica niente
china da che red mur poiché giotto dos
molto volentieri se o ma ti sei fatto
male cadendo dal cielo no perché sembri
uno angelo schiacciare marino christian
miche bel no ma si abbina benissimo ai
tatuaggi o sai che mi ricordi per un po
troppo troppo
edward cullen quello di twilight o
guarda chi non ho paura anzi se vuoi
mordimi pure cioè io ho capito io credo
tanto nelle energie in questo momento io
sento proprio dell'energia che proviene
da te verso di me ma fortissima
fortissimo e come se io fossi bisco come
se tu forse il biscotto e io ho il latte
che tu non la senti questa energia
strano che dai pettorali che hai io però
ti batto non mi chiedi se sono single
allora chi vi costoro che per uno come
te potrebbe fare follie
e cosa voleva bere champagne e
ovviamente amore grazie mille per questa
bottiglia di champagne ci vediamo ci
vediamo forse c'è da domandarsi mar dai
anch'io duro i cani da va bene purtroppo
far conoscere bebè il mio barboncino
l'odore rai non è in tutto il giorno in
cui ha detto come ti chiami marco
sicuro di chiamare di modulo marco non
è che mi sono abbracciata c'era da lui
mi ha lasciato e lui
no guarda
mi sta passando te lo giuro la ferita
che abbiamo s'estende margin andò però è
sentire guarda quindi per colpa del
rapporto conflittuale con tua madre sei
diventato crotone no assolutamente cioè
io io ho studiato psicologia
cioè tu non lo fai tanto per rubare tu
lo fai per attirare la sua attenzione
in realtà il problema punto e lei tu e
sentir chiamato da tua madre ha il vizio
del gioco sia alcolizzate spazi
perché non andiamo a casa tua ho proprio
voglia di coccolarvi tutta la notte e
andiamo dai
mazzarri anche come forte dei marmi
d'estate no vabbè ma come questi che non
siamo ai visti scusa un attimo
ciao amore si sono con anno siamo dopo
anche la società scusa era mio fidanzato
sai ho detto che dopo una vita per se
giochero con the social geloso che poi
vuol dire gli eterni deciso a piantare
ora zai nel senso ci passava una bella
serata ci vogliamo bene e io domani
torno da lui più felice che soddisfatta
quanti anni hai vice all ma è minorenne
io per te in prigione ci vado ci vado
subito in catena
anzi adesso secco da faccio che la mondo
tatuatore evitato il tuo nome come che
si chiami giuseppino nome di merda no no
no ti prego non te ne andare
nasce da mm nonni mancino in uno solo